à une famille russe pour le Noël
orthodoxe l'occasion aussi pour le
président russe de décréter un feu
général en Ukraine le premier depuis
l'invasion à la demande des autorités
religieuses de Russie
et du président turcohann
à compter de midi demain jusqu'à minuit
le lendemain les armes russes se
terrants tout le long de la ligne de
front invitant les forces ukrainiennes à
respecter elles aussi cette trêve de 36
heures
un répit bienvenue pour l'armée russe en
mauvaise posture depuis des mois encore
sonné par le bombardement de sa caserne
à maquiska le jour de l'an qui a fait au
moins 89 mars chez des mobilisés et
beaucoup de blessés mais c'est annonce
d'une trêve et reçue avec beaucoup de
scepticisme côté
Ukrainiens
ils vont peut-être arrêter tirés pour
une journée mais quelle différence cela
va faire du ce soldat c'est absurde et
cynique pour le Sénégal
le président
affirmé quant à lui que la guerre ne
finira que lorsque les soldats russes
quitteront son pays racine
pour renforcer leur position accuse
à Washington le président Biden doute
aussi de la sincérité de Vladimir
Poutine
c'est intéressant dit-il parce que le 25
décembre et le jour de l'an il n'hésite
pas à bombarder les hôpitaux et des
églises vestimente aussi que les Russes
veulent simplement se donner le temps de
respirer
Washington a du même souffle confirme il
envoie en Ukraine de blinder léger un
cadeau de Noël bienvenue d'autant plus
qu'il s'ajoute à des dons équivalents de
la France et de l'Allemagne
qui est en tout cas beaucoup ont déjà
choisi de s'aligner désormais sur la
calendrier grégorien en fait en Noël le
25 décembre
[Musique]
Alexandra qui dit ne plus vouloir
célébrer Noël de cette janvier en même
temps que les Russes un Noël qui a ses
yeux n'a rien de sain et si
Jean-François Bélanger Radio-Canada
Montréal